so at 10 years old when you get Hannah
Montana the whole world changes your dad
didn't want you to audition for Hannah
Montana why not because he was so scared
of that heartbreak you know he was so
scared of me which actually they cast
someone besides me first oh no kidding
I'm fascinated and they even did a pilot
without me and then they said that it
didn't work and they came back and
wanted me to do this and because I think
in somewhere inside of me that Hannah
Montana double life thing did work
because I did want to be all these
things but I also just wanted to be
normal the Hannah Montana story was here
you are regular girl
and if you put on a blonde wig you
suddenly become isn't that great and
yeah and no one knows that is great you
couldn't tell they were different girls
they were the same girl I went to all
with all my friends all my my yeah my
friend went to all my concerts with my
biggest fan and had no idea that you
were different how quick I don't know
how the Disney Channel works but in
other words you audition they give it to
someone else were you heartbroken did
you feel like this could be the role for
me the breakout thing to be on the
Disney Channel or you've never thought
about it like that right I never thought
about it like that because I never knew
what it was going to be do you remember
the audition I do I do I um went in and
weirdly enough I sang a song about the
beach which I sing a song about the
beach now who gave you the song to sing
they did me no me and one of my friends
that was at home that was a writer we
wrote this song and it says I'm going to
the beach this weekend me and some of my
best girlfriends uh putting on the
suntan lotion we're about to got a
little commotion I'm 10 by the way
trying on my brand new bikini gonna
drive a few boys crazy they're going to
jail hoping that the fun never ends
we're going to the beach this weekend
and I was gonna go to the beach my
grandma was gonna go with me to the
Hannah Montana audition and we were
gonna go to the beach isn't that amazing
the way you sing and and even with your
background as uh Billy Ray's daughter
all that you would think that the the
Disney Channel go jackpot but here you
got rejected that's unbelievable to me
but you know what every time the door
slams in your face I think you get back
up more determined you know every time
you get told no it's like
I believe in myself when you got the
part did you get a shitty contract by
industry standards here you are a kid
trying to make it so they can sign you
for anything right yeah I actually
um my name was Miley on the show right
so once I was done with the show I had
to make sure that I wasn't just like
they owned Miley forever right I have
these nightmares that I have to go back
that all of a sudden the show gets
called back and I've somewhere signed
saying like you know a Scientologist
billionaire contract that I've signed
that somewhere
um and so I feel like I might just have
to go back sometimes how soon do you
become aware that the show is really
taking off and I mean in a big way that
it's turning you into a recording star
how how the next day I went to go ride
roller coasters with my friends and
someone asking for autograph and I was
so stoked I like I got my picture taken
with this kid and I then it kind of
became a [ __ ] show right and I had to
leave and but that was so cool and then
it kept happening for a couple more
weeks and then I was wishing I really
was Hannah Montana but I really could
double life it